our 8 news now investigators continuing
to dig into the Staffing crisis
affecting your safety she made headlines
as the first woman to lead nhp tonight
the retired Colonel is speaking
exclusively about a lack of funding and
the road forward here's 8 News Now
did you get to a point where you just
thought
this is a systematic problem I don't
give up I'm very tenacious and I don't
give up and if I I'll go around I'll go
up I'll go under I'll go whatever it
takes to make it work that's probably
one of the reasons retired Colonel and
Carpenter became head of Nevada Highway
Patrol now Nevada State Police I loved
it she took over the job in October 2020
overseeing a staff of more than 600. you
can make a difference
right you I wake up every day and say
okay what am I going to do today how am
I going to impact the community how am I
going to impact my people but after 13
months with retirement on the horizon
she bowed out she says after years of
moving up the ladder years in leadership
she'd simply run out of steam you could
only ask for the bare necessities so
many times do you think you were given
the resources to make those changes
being in a state agency for 27 years
there's never enough resources and the
state usually runs very lean Carpenter
took over State Police when the agency
was already years into a funding and
Staffing crisis last year the eighties
now investigators found the department
pays the least among area law
enforcement it's been very very
difficult it's very challenging to
accomplish your goals and ensure that
your mission is accomplished when you
don't have enough staff you don't have
enough money you don't have enough
anything the fear is soon we won't have
enough Troopers the 8 news now
investigators have asked the Department
of Public Safety which oversees State
Police just how many Troopers have left
year over year in 2021 there were 98
vacancies out of about 500 positions at
the end of last year
131 spots needed to be filled when you
do find those people who love it like I
did they're not getting paid and they're
now paying more money into their
retirement for more than a decade
Carpenter and her predecessors have
sounded the alarm the 8 news now
investigators previously reported on a
presentation given to the legislature
just two years ago with these startling
statements Highway Patrol may get to the
point where they must turn away certain
calls for service and response times to
calls for service will continue to
increase do you feel like people were
even listening to you you know I think
they listened and I think some of the
legislature legislators even shed tears
over our words and what we said because
it was impactful I think it's difficult
because the state has a finite amount of
money that finite amount of money has
now created a public safety emergency
three or four Troopers are covering the
entire Las Vegas Valley on some nights
you were asking people for help yes
every chance here we still are so you
know when I was there my Mantra was I'm
gonna do less with less with Carpenter
watching from the sidelines the question
for lawmakers as they head into this
session what is Rock Bottom I can't see
how the state of Nevada goes forward
without paying these people what they're
worth I just don't understand they'll
just keep leaving
the union representing Troopers says
their members haven't received adequate
wages in 15 years over that time frame
both Republicans and Democrats held
power in Carson City now only time will
tell and see if those lawmakers will
hear these alarm Bells this time and
take some action along Di and the I-15
I'm David charns 8 News Now
Governor Lombardo made a campaign
promise to raise State Police salary
citing our Aidan's now investigators
reporting